So in the lazy model, as we saw
in the picture, there were less communication events. Which
means you have less messages that are flowing
through the network, in order to carry out the
coherence actions, compared to the eager model. But
there is a downside to the lazy model as
well. And that is, at the point of
acquisition, you don't have all the coherence actions complete.
And therefore you may have to incur more latency at the point of acquire to
wait for all the coherence actions to get
complete. So that's the cons one might think
about for the lazy model compared to the
eager model. Procrastination helps in releasing the number
of messages. But it could result in more
latency at the point of acquiring the lock.